tout normal et là c'est une fleur
femelle
on reconnaît toujours la fleur femelle
parce que en dessous elle a comme une
petite couche qui commence à se former à
partir de quelques graines venues des
états unis des horticulteurs de saint
martin des bois sont parvenus à faire
pousser une centaine de courge géante la
citrouille et les courges enfin les gens
dont la connotation aussi avec les
enfants halloween halloween quoi ça fait
peur et que là ils sont plus émerveillé
et voilà quoi ils voyent les courges
différemment du coup avec sens de la
pédagogie on leur explique de la graine
jusqu'à la germination jusqu'à la
récolte elles sont émerveillés parce
qu'ils ne reviennent pas la vitesse qu
une course comme ça peut pousser en
cette mode d'emploi les maîtresses ont
pu faire ce matin le cours de sciences
naturelles dans les serres directement
[Musique]
une petite graine les avaient sous la
pluie tout petit peu le soleil après une
telle visite
le cours de sciences naturelles sera
assurément surnaturel